this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the ad free creator controlled
streaming service when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
[Music]
history is full of examples of people in
power trying to restrict
access to certain material whether it's
literature journalism
music websites or some other supposedly
inappropriate or dangerous content
as long as there has been a difference
of opinion there have been attempts to
suppress those deemed antagonistic
towards the status quo the
execution of socrates the burning of
mayan books by spanish bishops
cambridge's banning of darwin's origin
of species book burnings in nazi germany
all instances of those in positions of
authority attempting to suppress access
to knowledge and dissenting opinion and
the practice continues to this day
both in the open and covertly in this
episode we'll consider the modern
forefront of the censorship battle
the internet and what is to be done
about the practice of banning and
manipulating information
if you were asked to name an instance of
modern day censorship the first example
that would probably come to mind is
china's intense curation of the internet
in their country
according to most experts china's
censorship is the most sophisticated and
comprehensive in the world
with severe restrictions placed on both
publishing and accessing certain
content the chinese government strictly
monitors and polices internet activity
and are quick to remove content deemed
objectionable this tendency has earned
their policy the nickname
the great firewall of china but china
isn't the only country engaging in
suppression of information
in fact most governments are engaged in
some form of censorship over the
internet in their respective countries
if you're familiar with my content
you're probably aware of what prompted
this week's video
for those out of the loop here's a quick
rundown last week i posted a video
called the cia is a terrorist
organization
unsurprisingly it was instantly
demonetized but what happened next was
pretty alarming
later in the day i started getting
reports from patrons that my video was
no longer appearing in their
subscription feed
then i got word that subscribers weren't
being notified of the new upload
finally the really strange part what had
begun to happen
and this is still the case as of writing
the script is that even if you search
the exact title of my video
it still won't appear in youtube search
results this had never happened to me
before
a few months earlier i had posted a
video about america's police brutality
problem
that one got age gated but was still
searchable it also earned me a visit
from the department of homeland security
this made me think why was my cia video
content that did not violate any of
youtube's terms and conditions
getting a harsher treatment than a video
that did explicitly show violence
i tweeted at youtube to ask for an
explanation and to no one's surprise
they lied their response was that it
sometimes takes a few days for the video
to show up in search results
as someone who has been posting to
youtube for years and has uploaded
hundreds of videos
i knew this to be false if you search a
video by its exact title and especially
if you add the channel name to the
search it will
come up the conclusion i reached is that
because of google's contract with the
cia
youtube was obligated to shadow ban my
video you can read my very long twitter
thread on the topic by following the
link in the description
this blatant suppression of content
critical of a us entity
made me think i should probably cover
the topic of censorship so with that out
of the way
let's take a look at the state of the
internet and the suppression of
information
you may be thinking that this whole
video will be a misguided tantrum about
free speech
let's start there there are certain
groups and outlets that routinely make a
fuss about supposed censorship of their
content
prageru is perhaps the most obvious
example they claim that platforms like
facebook and youtube are suppressing
their right to free speech by hiding
their content
first of all this is not the case the
whole conservative ideas are censored
shtick is just a bit of theater
as evidenced by the data on which
content is shared and distributed most
heavily on social media
spoiler alert it's stuff like prageru i
do believe that everyone should have the
right to express themselves within the
limits of a platform's terms and
conditions
if content is suppressed while not
violating the rules that is unacceptable
whatever the ideological positions
espoused in that content
if prageru were actually being censored
i would be 100
against it they're not but that's beside
the point the distinction we need to
make is where the right to free speech
actually applies
your first amendment right to the
freedom of expression only applies where
the government is involved
the state is prohibited from suppressing
your right to express yourself in a
public forum such as a town hall meeting
or in the case of knight vs trump a
presidential twitter account
after donald trump blocked several users
from viewing his feed a federal court
ruled in favor of those users
saying that the president had no right
to restrict access to what he had turned
into an official government forum
private companies have no such
obligation to allow you to express
yourself
this is where we need to pause for a
moment and consider the nature of the
internet
when the internet was first developed
many people had high hopes that it would
become a sort of digital commons
a place where people could gather and
freely exchange information
sort of like a giant public library as
we all know
that is not what became of the internet
as soon as corporations figured out just
how lucrative this new frontier would be
the project was poisoned and it became
just another tentacle of the modern
market
in today's modern internet all of our
activity and information passes through
the hands of private companies who have
final say over what is accessible
visible and permissible on the internet
people tend to forget that google is not
some universal public
utility it's part of a giant company
that exists within the internet
when you're engaging with a google
property like youtube your right to free
speech is checked at the door
whereas your physical world is
controlled by your country's government
your digital life is ruled by massive
corporations and a handful of absurdly
wealthy individuals
it is against the interest of these
companies and billionaires to allow the
free exchange of information on their
platforms
instead sites like youtube and twitter
are meticulously curated in order to
mediate the conversation and most
effectively
monetize our traffic youtube tells you
what to watch next
and it's always videos that will make
them money the ones from big channels
videos that are monetized and highly
shareable like for example the
aforementioned prageru
same with twitter and facebook your
served tailored ads and recommendations
that align with what those companies
want you to engage with
this is the problem in a nutshell in a
world where the internet is a necessity
for most people
where our news is online or shopping or
education
does it seem appropriate that these
corporations operate almost entirely
outside the control of governing bodies
and the general populace
perhaps it's time to consider a new
internet bill of rights to protect
reasonable speech online
the internet at this point is
essentially a public utility based
solely on its necessity in modern life
sites like youtube and facebook are
essentially monopolies
there are no real alternatives but these
companies are not regulated like
monopolies
take your local water company for
example it's a public utility
and everyone is served at the same level
if the water utility were run like
facebook
they could divert water away from
undesirable areas and towards certain
other areas that have somehow earned
their favor in opaque ways
we're still very new to the internet and
especially social media
the world wide web has only really
existed since 1990
and facebook has only been around since
2004. the massive amount of
transformative change that has occurred
in the past 30 years has vastly outpaced
our understanding of what the internet
could be
by now it should be clear that the
internet will be the dominating factor
of modern life for the foreseeable
future
and we need to take it seriously we need
to make plans for how to ensure that the
internet doesn't simply become a
propaganda tool to be wielded by massive
corporations that are free from
oversight
whether this means transforming the
internet into a public utility or
building an entirely new
unmonetized alternative to the corporate
internet is up for debate
but it's certainly something we need to
consider just as libraries serve as an
effective public institution allowing
for the democratization of learning
a public alternative to the internet as
it currently exists could democratize
the flow of information in our digital
age
free from the coercion of private
interests manipulated news feeds and
targeted advertising
but to return to the issue of my cia
video for a moment there is another
factor to consider
while multi-billion dollar corporations
are the main driver of internet curation
and censorship in america
many of these companies have lucrative
contracts with government agencies
including the cia sometimes there will
be actual instances of government
censorship in the united states
i believe my cia video is one example if
youtube would just be transparent about
their reasoning for the shadow ban i
wouldn't complain
but the fact that they tried to be
covert about it then lied about the
cause is alarming
the cia and the military-industrial
complex have long waged a sort of
psychological campaign to manufacture
consent among the american public
the department of war became the
department of defense every action the
u.s takes abroad is in the name of
national security
even when we're meddling in tiny nations
that could never do anything to harm us
even if they wanted to
censorship is not simply a matter of
restricting access to content critical
of the status quo
it also entails promoting material
that's designed to reinforce that status
quo
to manufacture a sense of patriotism
american exceptionalism and fear of the
unknown
we need to be aware of the extent to
which the powers that be
are influencing the content we consume
online and that those powers are not
only government agencies
but also powerful corporations that
benefit from our country's war-like
nature
[Music]
as you know youtube treats its creators
horribly the shadow banning of my last
video is just the most recent example
stuff like that is why my creator
friends and i teamed up to build nebula
a streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization since nebula is all about
creating thoughtful content
we've partnered with curiositystream an
established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
their series on the internet which is a
great watch if you enjoyed this video
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free for a limited time
curiosity stream is offering 26 off
their annual plan
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series
on the resurgence of fascism you can
also watch all my videos as they were
intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week